[Música]
mientras en la ciudad desde que tengo es
un arrastre
tanto a los dioses
las ciudades son actores de personas
están graves y siendo más personas
insular personas viven en el sector
rural
sólo concentra la oportunidad toda la
interacción de cargar adicción es muy
importante la diversidad de emoción
y la reacción de la ciudad a una persona
va a ser cumplida me siento así 300 la
naciones unidas pronostica que en los
próximos 15 años vamos a tener un millón
de personas más
qué significa esto como dimensional
implica
un completo
[Música]
pero si lo logramos
no siento entre la proa del 50
ms
y ya
si nosotros cambiar todos los preceptos
desde la cosa y empezar una economía que
tuvieran emociones meta podríamos llegar
a mantener
sí no
[Música]
esto tiene consecuencias sociales muy
difícil pero sobre todo la capacidad de
acciones de alimentos idea
y todo tiene que ver como construyendo
unas ciudades
es tu próxima quincena
[Música]
la maternidad y bien por lo tanto es un
sol que no tomas en el cargo
además de ahora
tenemos que generar ciudades que sean
amables atractivas en una sociedad
transformando en todo aquello que
queremos ser
esto implica un montón de cosas su memo
le ganó al desafío que tenemos que
generar viviendas dignas en barrios
buenos transporte que sea cómodo y
eficiente servicios públicos que sean
debuten estándar ciudades que sean
capaces de incluir a todas las personas
distintas y además que sean
suficientemente integradas para que
todos tengan la posibilidad de
desarrollarse y tener buena calidad de
vida
pareciera ser un desafío inalcanzable
lo que queda claro es que ningún actor
por su y por sí solo es capaz de dar una
respuesta sistémica a todo este conjunto
de elementos
pero yo soy optimista porque estamos en
un momento donde se está cambiando el
paradigma estamos haciendo las cosas de
manera nueva y en el centro de todos los
buenos ejemplos y de todas las
iniciativas que uno quisiera replicar
para mejorar las ciudades hay una
práctica común algo que las une y las
transforma en una nueva manera de hacer
y en la colaboración
que parece obvio
pero no es tan simple
porque colaborar no es fácil
de hecho llevamos décadas elaborando un
discurso de la colaboración pero hemos
sido mucho menos eficientes en ponerla
en práctica tenemos primero que nada un
sistema que promueve la competencia la
especialización que promueve la
jerarquía y además hemos ido
construyendo las ciudades en base a un
sistema que busca todos los beneficios
económicos en el corto plazo
además se promueven mecanismos de
producción y de consumo que tienen el
sistema estresado hasta el límite y por
encima tenemos sistemas de
administración de la ciudad que están
orientados o están diseñados para
abordar los problemas en forma parcelada
y tienen grandes dificultades de
interactuar en conjunto coordinadamente
en el territorio
colaborar no es fácil pero que es
colaborar
el sociólogo richard sennett lo define
como un intercambio donde los
participantes se benefician del
encuentro y logran cosas que no podrían
lograr en forma individual también se
plantea que la colaboración es una
habilidad algo que se practica se
desarrolla y que requiere mucha
paciencia requiere habilidades que nos
permitan primero que nada escuchar
además tener una actitud de encuentro
con el otro donde uno puede exponer las
divergencias que son muy válidas sin
llegar a una confrontación o una
competencia requiere buscar los puntos
que son comunes los encuentros las
convergencias pero también manejar y
gestionar los puntos que no se van a
poder acordar
no es fácil de hecho es mucho más fácil
defender con vehemencia una idea y
confrontarse al resto genera necesidad
genérica entidad mueve de alguna manera
el alma a luchar por algo pero nuestras
ciudades requieren acuerdos requieren de
acuerdos para poder ser planificadas
diseñadas operadas y también construidas
y esos acuerdos tienen esas formas de
colaboración se tienen que desarrollar a
distintas escalas
este año hace un tiempo vino a chile
michael rose el director del comité y
fuerza de este comité es un grupo de
personas que vienen del mundo privado
del mundo público de la academia del
mundo de la cultura del arte e incluso
del mundo del deporte y se reúnen a
trabajar sistemáticamente para buscar
maneras de desarrollar la ciudad de
sídney ellos tienen un lema que es
paradójico que se llama colaborar para
competir porque quieren que sidney sea
una ciudad que le vaya bien en el
contexto nacional de australia pero
también el contexto mundial
y lo interesante es que este comité no
tiene una relación transaccional con
ninguno de sus miembros es decir no
trabaja para los componentes que están
adentro ni tiene que responder a su fin
a la gente que lo financia o que
participa son muy independientes tienen
como un horizonte de trabajo de largo
plazo por lo tanto son capaces de
plantear cosas que los ciclos de
gobierno no pueden abordar y trabajan en
conjunto en colaboración con otro
organismo que se llama la comisión for
sydney comité de la comisión pero que
está dentro del gobierno de la ciudad y
es el organismo encargado de planificar
y de operar la ciudad por lo tanto
generar recomendaciones de política
pública de planificación urbana que
después son incorporadas por la ciudad y
estipulada
esta buena forma de colaboración muy
interesante pero no es la única tenemos
también el caso de la ciudad de
copenhague
aquí un organismo definido en forma
consensuada con un montón de actores
también 33 elementos 3 componentes que
dan forma a la visión generar una ciudad
que sea vivible agradable para ir una
ciudad responsable con el medio ambiente
y una ciudad con algo que se podría
hacer que es con obra
estas tres estos tres objetivos son la
punta de la super de un conjunto de
políticas de proyectos de incentivos de
trabajo con la comunidad
que están todos orientados a construir
bajo esas tres premisas una ciudad que
incorpora a los ciudadanos y el de maco
que es lo que hace especial este sistema
porque todos los elementos que están en
juego para poder construir esos tres
objetivos implican un trabajo con la
comunidad un trabajo donde se fomenta la
participación la creatividad y también
la interacción entre los ciudadanos
nosotros tenemos que diseñar nuestras
propias formas de gobernanza
participativa tenemos que ponernos de
acuerdo en nuestras ciudades sobre qué
es ese bien común cuál es el punto de
convergencia donde no no hay un
desacuerdo respecto a lo que queremos
hacer
formas de acción con nada que permitan
que todos los actores públicos privados
academia comunidades ong trabajen
construyendo eso que está con estar
común y es parte de lo que todos quieren
hay una oportunidad acá porque se están
cambiando en este momento los modelos de
gobierno de los de las regiones y de las
áreas metropolitanas por lo tanto existe
un espacio para diseñar nuevas formas de
gobernanza que permitan la colaboración
por el momento podemos operar en otra
escala porque existen maneras de ir
probando esto los proyectos esto es un
proyecto en cuenta que también seguimos
allá
que cumple tres funciones al mismo
tiempo
es una planta de generación de energía y
calor al mismo tiempo en lugar de
disposición final de un montón de
residuos que aquí se incineran de forma
por supuesto con tecnología que no
contamina
pero ah
en tercer lugar
en una cancha de esquí una cancha
artificial en un lugar donde no hay
cerros de una ciudad muy plana por lo
tanto se genera un espacio de
interacción social un espacio de
recreación y de reactivación de la zona
donde esto es históricamente la planta
termoeléctrica para que se transforme en
un barrio atractivo trabajando fuera de
los nichos de especialidad rompiendo
sistemas legales que impiden las
colaboraciones generando nuevos modelos
de negocio es posible colaborar a nivel
técnico y a nivel profesional para
generar proyectos así inteligentes que
son capaces de solucionar tres cosas o
un dicho que me carga pero es como matar
tres pájaros de un tiro' porque
necesitamos por la velocidad que tenemos
que hacer las cosas que sean así
eficientes las soluciones
en chile también hemos hecho cosas como
esta con procesos largos con mucho
aprendizaje por medio yo tuve el honor
de trabajar en la etapa inicial del
parque víctor jara que una acción
conjunta ante el ministerio de vivienda
y el ministerio de obras públicas para
que la inversión que se tenía que hacer
en una infraestructura de evacuación de
aguas lluvia fuera tuviera un impacto
urbano positivo por lo tanto lo que se
diseñó en vez de un ducto fue un partido
notable
este proyecto tiene muchos aprendizajes
detrás aquí trabajaron enorme una enorme
cantidad de personas tienen muchos
dueños muchos padres o madres y también
el proceso tuvo hay muchas cosas
perfectibles pero es un ejemplo de lo
que podemos hacer además tenemos una
herramienta nueva hace muy poco que son
los convierte en los convenios de
programación vinculantes que hacen que
distintos organismos públicos puedan
acordar una inversión conjunta y eso
queda establecido en el tiempo eso no es
un acuerdo que queda legalmente
establecido por lo tanto es otra puerta
y otro ejemplo de lo que podemos hacer
se requieren acciones múltiples
multipropósito y multidisciplinaria
nosotros tenemos una enorme capacidad de
integrar saberes técnicos y
profesionales y esa manera de hacer
también tenemos que trasladarla tenemos
que potenciar las a nivel de comunidades
yo les traigo un ejemplo de amsterdam
mentales
el ms una entidad que se llama el
amsterdam metropolitan solutions lleva
años promoviendo el trabajo a través de
la metodología de los urban living lapse
son laboratorios vivos de la ciudad
donde en un contexto real y con una
comunidad concreta interactúan en el
mundo público la cadena y el mundo
privado para testear alguna solución y
llegar a un nuevo invento
todo
es mandatado de algún modo por el
gobierno de la ciudad que tiene desafíos
que tiene que resolver problemas pero no
lo puede hacer solo internamente y pone
digamos el problema en este espacio para
que se resuelva en forma colaborativa
acá hay dos ejemplos de soluciones que
se han diseñado acá eso muchas más
por ejemplo mobiliario urbano que está
esto imprimiendo en 3-d por material de
reciclado de plástico con una forma y
liviandad y rapidez que tienen que ver
con los requerimientos locales o los
robots que son botes auto cómodo que
funcionan en los canales permiten
testear el como este mundo de los
vehículos autónomos sirven para
transportar cargas o personas y también
se pueden acoplar para generar puentes
en momentos específicos cuando se
requiere más conectividad a través de
los canales
nosotros en el centro innovaciones
ciudades también alguna vez alguna vez
hace un par de años desarrollamos un
proyecto que fue un espacio de
integración entre las pequeñas y
medianas empresas el mundo
público y la academia para generar
soluciones digitales que tuvieran
relación con los desafíos de la región
metropolitana trabajamos durante un año
con 50 pymes en base a cinco desafíos
que los fueron votados por la comunidad
y finalmente hubieron cinco ganadores
que recibieron financiamiento para
desarrollar y poner al servicio de la
comunidad
soluciones sufrimientos
otro espacio creado para fomentar una
colaboración y una cooperación
y finalmente quiero hablar de ciudad
emergente que una ong se dedica a hacer
algo que es el punto base como el
cimiento de la colaboración ellos
generan encuentros entre vecinos y en
ese encuentro generan comunidad
seguridad
amor por el barrio compromiso capacidad
de generación de proyectos y sobre todo
entrenan esas habilidades que son
necesarias para cooperar
necesitamos instancias que congreguen y
que fomenten la cooperación tenemos que
crearlas y para eso se requieren
liderazgos se requieren entidades que
sean capaces de proveer esos espacios y
también que todos nosotros tengamos la
voluntad de desarrollar las habilidades
yo al arar y define en su libro que
somos una especie que maneja el mundo
porque podemos colaborar en pos de un
objetivo común es muy importante que
definamos esos objetivos comunes que
orientemos nuestra acción y sobre todo
que cada uno de nosotros desde nuestras
capacidades de conocimiento podamos
colaborar en construir esas ciudades que
queremos
porque solo si colaboramos vamos a estar
a la altura de los desafíos de nuestros
tiempos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah